[Music]
as we close out another year dominated
at times at least by the covid pandemic
we are taking a closer look at the
health stories and the trends that could
Define the year ahead 2022 saw the
rollout of the anti-viral drug Pax lovid
along with variant specific vaccines to
fight covid we also witnessed a
worldwide outbreak of mpox and the
Resurgence of polio in parts of New York
State and right now Americans are
battling an unusually early
RSV and severe flu season CBS News
medical contributor Dr David Aegis joins
us now with more on all this Dr Aegis
let's begin with the covet conversation
which I think waned as the year went on
people began to move on there was a new
normal the president said it was over
what can we expect in the new year so
the good of this year right is that the
vaccines have held so unfortunately over
15 percent of people in the United
States we're number 70 in the world in
terms of boosters 15 of people have
gotten this new bivalent booster not
enough six plus months out you need to
get it it's what we're going to see is
if we can keep the booster rate up I
think we're going to be okay in the year
ahead if we don't we're going to start
to see more and more people getting sick
because covet numbers are going up
across the country with the new variant
the vaccine works against serious
illness but we have to stay on our toes
but that's what's so frustrating to
people Dr egg is because you get
vaccinated you do all the right things
and you still get it and we're still
dealing with it you do but you don't get
that ill is that yeah you're not being
hospitalized but you're right we're
praying in 2023 that we will get a
vaccine or a booster that will block
spread and symptomatology with this
virus that'll increase what we call
mucosal immunity to actually give us
protection which the current ones
protect against serious illness but not
this when we were in the thick of covet
and fighting against it it seemed like
we kept hearing the narrative that we
weren't as prepared as we should have
been are we now more prepared for the
next pandemic I better hope we are or
we're in trouble I mean so a pandemic by
definition it means we don't know what's
going to happen and I think we now have
systems in place that we're going to be
better we're going to be better
collecting data which we didn't do well
during covid we're going to have
manufacturing ready for vaccines and
small molecules these antivirals and
we've been normalized that if we have to
wear a mask we will wear a mask and we
know the behaviors remember in the
beginning about touching surfaces about
six feet and about all those things
right we were normalizing these ideas
which are here so we're going to be
better with a new virus look at M pox or
the old monkey pox it's had a you know
it came up and then we were able to deal
with it a little bit slow but we dealt
with it rather well in this country
right I think we're going to be a lot
better in the year ahead yeah so we had
MPX we had RSV severe flu season polio a
Resurgence of polio like the 10 plagues
yes so do you think that this this is
our new normal dealing with these
viruses is this really what life is now
we have to adjust to that yes I'm trying
to figure out when should you freak out
and when should you know right so you
freak out based on your pre-existing
conditions right so the only people
being hospitalized now with covid are
elderly or people with medical
conditions
it's figure 94 of our country has
already had Covenant wow 9.4 we've all
had it have you had it I have had it in
August and so I am not a November we've
all been exposed to it we all have some
immunity you couple that with the
vaccines we're in a pretty good spot but
obviously we have to keep that up with
the boosters which is unfortunate and
nobody wants it but we have to do it so
medicine is one of those fields that
seems to be like right next door to just
pure magic right things that come out of
the field do miraculous things or it
feels that way anyway like my daughter
got a little eye infection the doctor
gives you drops it clears up in like two
days with that kind of as Prelude what
are you excited about in this year and
also looking ahead for next year in
terms of advancement yeah give us some
good news because we need it all right
so the good news is I think every parent
in this country that is watching today
their shoulders will come down when I
tell them this is that very soon we're
going to have an RSV vaccine so the data
look fantastic it should be approved by
the FDA for get this mothers so when
you're pregnant we give it to you and
when your baby he's born the first six
months they have the protection and then
for young children and elderly and
that's a big one there right we're
seeing now hospitalizations across the
country from RSV pediatric icu's full
and we're going to now be able to
vaccinate pregnant women and others with
this vaccine and that's a big one the
other one that I'm really excited about
is Big Data artificial intelligence or
AI is going to enable us to Care better
they're going to be able to read our
scans our pathology reports look at
things to enable every person in the
country to get the best care so right
now you may have a remarkable doctor and
a hospital in New York City what AI will
do will make every doctor good doctor is
great and that's going to be the new era
we've normalized using data hopefully
during covid and so I think that's going
to be a big thing and it's going to be
cost effective everyone's going to be
able to do this and it's really going to
improve care across the country so that
I'm excited about yeah and your
enthusiasm I have to say is infectious
you were on this show earlier this month
talking about your new show the checkup
which is on pair amount plus number one
I have to say again it's knockout I love
how you do it you're so good at it where
you're just talking to celebrities who
are having problems like we all do very
well done so that's good news other good
news you and that freaking green sweater
can we just have an acknowledgment that
he's wearing something other than black
there we go and it looks good on you
how's it feel are you wincing are you
cringing no I can handle it I mean you
have to realize I'm about to go on and
then the remarkable to you here at CBS
Morning said well we happen to have
something in Nate's closet that will go
better with Christmas morning yeah it's
so great thank you Nate for sharing your
clothing uh yeah you may look like it's
a fit for Nate but the fact that wasn't
oh Tony
all the time yeah no it was Tony's
closet and I I appreciate you sharing it
looks like you can't wait to take out
it's working on you it's working on okay
thank you sir thank you